ja heute müssen flaschenpost und wird
kurz ganz ohne frage genau die hand ist
einfach ganz viele fragen geschickt
respektive der redaktion und die relativ
locker toppen
[Musik]
wie erkennt man einen guten freund oder
eine gute freundin corinna zeiten sind
so viele erst meinen bekanntenkreis
verschwunden
der gute freund erkennt man in
unsicheren lag das hat glaubt da ist und
er ist ein guter freund ist ich bin sehr
stolz dass wir mit text muss ich jetzt
dafür ein schlechtes gewissen hat
nein die frage warum ich die fragliche
brav unsere moralischen organza ich
glaube sich zurecht ruf und das zeigt
dass trotz was eigentlich moralismus
angelockt werden und was nicht variiert
je nach kultur und zieht und fleisch
us-daten diese mit ihren könnt ist
definitiv wird im orange frag ich glaube
sogar dass wir das fleisch esse mal
anders wird danke die über das klar
verhandelt und klassik das ganze fleisch
haben wir ein großzügiger dass das ein
problemloses in trier
warum finde ich so häufig meine zweite
sockel ist wichtig ist die frage wer hat
kleines problem ist dass minister oft
löcher bekommt also falschen weg will
dafür steht aber dass mit der sorge
jetzt im ernst sendung mit der maus
großartige sandig hannover - and data
ist es wurde das waschmaschinen zu
tatsächlich so gefrustet und entlang
gegen die wir trommeln den könig und
dann hingen und dann gibt es die fusilli
irgendwas was bleibt nach corona vom
neuen normal handtasche nein man eben
nur drei chris lee
nein stärker die sehnsucht nach 8a tiefe
beziehung so aber die nächste frage wie
könnte der mensch anstelle von
misstrauen vorteilsnahme und missbrauch
dauerhaft vertrauen fairness kooperation
und respekt schaffen
ich glaube vor in der hose und fotos
also das braucht tägliche beides also
die otto er zieht sich wegen wird der
schlüssel habe ich das gefühl nicht nur
ein erzählt vom verstand sondern ein vom
harz also mitgefühl versuche vorschlag
besucher vorbildes schaffte zu üben und
sonders sicher gesellschafters die
stimme und das begünstigt werde der
mensch ist nicht von natur ist weder gut
noch schlecht und beide sie sich und man
muss irgendwie das ambiente schaffen als
botschafter für die für den menschen der
sich die beste sicht ausland wann werden
menschen die der menschen statt
marionetten die frage was er mit ihren
marionetten ein thema das die person
nicht auf zwang spiel durch konventionen
es geht ja das schöne zitat von jean
jacques rousseau der mensch wird frei
geboren und liegt in ketten und die
ketten wurden so meint ist natürlich
zivilisation sind wir alle mehr die
internetnutzer in konvention während der
fahrt genannt aber natürlich haben wir
dank überhaupt mitmachen und geschult wo
mein geschmack ist wichtig die ganze hat
so ob es wieder fehlende metrics also
das heißt mit innere realität was man
vor kritisch um es in die marionette von
der realität gar nicht geht und dass er
sofort über das waldbild noch danke ja
ich meine die große digital kommt sagen
der offizier recht ich kenne diese immer
besser das mehr selber kennen wird
busacca in zukunft und wenn da war ist
das verhalten so dass man gezielt die
produkte konsumieren über in stuttgart
es ist nicht so gut bestellt um 83 der
mensch ist ihr und ist einziger
exzentrische tiere wiederum
facebook-seite sich nämlich das tier wo
weiß dass es tierisch oder meinte sagt
auch klaus mit sie ich würde sagen ob
der mensch ist einzigartig und hat mit
der fähigkeit des ganztags oder wartung
zu setzen
so stieg die lacher schutz und gar nicht
also 50 stieg sie aber was sind die
zusammenhänge dass der mensch was sind
die zusammenhänge dass der mensch das
gut sein als individuum viel er schafft
den aus gemeinschaft
das verstehe ich nicht ganz so gut sie
ihre einfache gesellschaft würde ich
einen tag im gegenteil es muss so gute
werte also müssen wir dir und also
ruhiger und der zivilisation werden nur
vor allem der respekt vor der schulter
schauen wurdest du hat mit der
sozialisation dass der andere mit einem
uni machen ist extrem wichtig zum zur
sprache kleidungs bilder von mir glaube
ich umgekehrt gesellschaft frau ist gute
menschen machen aber es gibt natürlich
die berühmte experiment milgram und zu
wieder gezeigt wurden ist gar die gruppe
mit gruppendruck und so weiter neigen
wenn sie irgendwie total krass sagt es
mache amoralische nachts machen ich habe
das phänomen werde ich das noch machen
sollen hier wird machen aber allen
umständen und dual socket das ist
richtige was da gemacht wird ja
nationalsozialismus stalinismus und
twitter sind ein phänomen der masse
besitzt
[Musik]